cloudy picture of the capitol there
democratic senator elizabeth warren is
urging the senate to take action to
support abortion rights after a leaked
draft of a majority opinion shows the
supreme court could be set to overturn
the landmark 1973 abortion rights ruling
roe v wade in her book persist now on
paperback warren writes in the same way
that congress passed laws to provide
access to health care think medicare and
medicaid congress should pass a law to
protect nationwide access to abortion
but such a bill would face tough odds
passing the senate and senator warner
joins us now tough odds is an
understatement do i have that right you
do you don't have the votes for it but
you're going to go forward to make
everybody vote what's the purpose of
that we want to get everybody on the
record because i think most of all we
have to remember
who will be affected
by this supreme court decision it's not
well-to-do women well-to-do women can
still get on an airplane fly to another
state fly out of the country
if they need to to have access to an
abortion who is this going to fall on
it's going to fall on poor women it's
going to fall on women of color it's
going to fall on girls who are molested
by a family member it's going to fall on
people who were raped it's going to fall
on the mama who right now is already
working two jobs to try to support the
children she has
this is about making sure that everyone
in this country has a right to make the
decision for themselves about a
pregnancy yeah we just saw a map on the
screen that said certain or likely um to
to end abortion
when you look at some of these states
where the numbers are not as high as so
all you know the overall national
numbers of at least 60 and sometimes 80
percent you'll find where people support
this
why not leave it up to the states when
you have so many where the numbers may
not be that high
and you look at that map and you see how
many are almost certain to try and to
get rid of it you know actually i i do
want to focus very much
on the idea of what it means to outlaw
abortion i lived in an america where
abortion was illegal
but it didn't mean that all abortions
stopped it just meant the safe legal
abortions stopped i lived in an america
where
women bled to death from back alley
abortions i lived in an america where
women developed infections uh horrible
complications from unclean abortions i
lived in an america
where young women took their lives
rather than go forward
with an abortion with a pregnancy that
they could not manage look we pass laws
at the federal level to decide minimum
wage to decide access to health care
this is about protecting not the people
with power this is about protecting all
of the people in our country who don't
have senator senator what you're saying
is true and and yet there are states
that have said despite that we want to
live by a different principle right and
a common refrain you hear is if you
don't like those laws in your state you
should just move what do you say to that
we don't do that anyplace else in our
federal government we don't say if you
don't like the minimum wage
in alabama move somewhere else we say as
a nation
we care for each other and we decide for
example right that work
is worth a certain amount we decide for
example on medicaid that there's going
to be for the poorest among us at least
some access
to health care we decide this for
children to make sure that there's going
to be money we decide this on food and
we should decide this on this basic
health decision
that will hit the most vulnerable among
us
those of us who feel like oh we're in
states where this will never happen
first of all we can't turn our backs
on the rest of those who will be hurt
but secondly remember what this opinion
is about
it has opened the door
to a whole lot of ugliness yeah open the
door to the question
contraception
uh criminalizing
uh a woman who seeks an abortion will
every miscarriage now be investigated
will women be charged if they're
working too many hours and put their
pregnancy at risk
this is a kind of invasion
that if the supreme court has its way
here and we don't fight back at the
federal level
could touch the lives of every one of us
yeah just like you're saying now in the
book you write you believe in a woman's
choice no matter how difficult the
decision
but there's a question should there be
any limits on abortions you know i i'm
going to put it this way i think that
the woman who is most affected should be
at the heart of this of course i think
that she should be able to call on
her partner right her mother
her priest her rabbi
she should be able to bring in the
people she needs
but in a pregnancy i don't believe that
it is the state that should intervene
with its heavy hand
and make the decision
it is an extraordinary thing for a
government to tell a person they need to
go forward with a pregnancy that's right
all right uh senator elizabeth warren we
have a lot more we could talk to you
about please come back come back please
come back i appreciate you being here
the paperback edition of persist is out
right now we'll be right back